[Music]
America hello I'm not sure if I'm in the
right place a thousand there's now a
child in South America died of
starvation joke another you I would lose
you're wearing a dog is there a pocket
on the back this is go to Dave &
Buster's okay I'm kissing happy I can't
do the noises smooth
I'm sorry I got you me you look exactly
alike
that's what's so hot about it's like
hooking up with yourself like stevia
this is amazing yeah I make dolls out of
human hair how's Thursday I know you
from your ass better than I know your
face but we all know is the star of the
show here dude and a dude dude
what are you a hot diggity dog and a
scallywag to boot hey I did not just
fart oh that's a woman's fart oh is it
Kirk I told you when we met that I hate
music how you do this is Halliburton
fat-cat lunch is on me I have a
girlfriend
so do I straight here ugly hands down
like I'm nervous oh yeah
you still have your performance bit
right we really are witches our sphere
were gigantic humongous witnesses
[Music]
you